Practiquemos sumar y restar números negativos.
El primer ejemplo que revisaremos es 2 - 3.
Ahora sólo estoy restando un número
positivo de otro número positivo,
pero es posible que ya se hayan dado cuenta de
que estamos restando un número mayor de uno menor,
así que probablemente o definitivamente el
resultado será un número negativo. Pero pensemos
un poco en esto. Voy a dibujar una recta numérica,
aquí está mi recta numérica, aquí tenemos el 0,
el 1, el 2, este es -1, -2. Podríamos comenzar en
2, tenemos 2 justo aquí, y le vamos a restar 3,
así que nos vamos a mover tres posiciones
a la izquierda en la recta numérica,
vamos a movernos tres a la izquierda: 1, 2, 3, y
eso nos lleva a -1, es igual a -1. Ahora hagamos
algunas variantes. Imaginemos qué pasaría si
tuviéramos -2 -3, esto fue 2 positivo - 3. Ahora
pensemos en -2 - 3, una vez más dibujemos nuestra
recta numérica y pondremos aquí el 0, este es -1,
-2, -3, -4, -5, -6 y podría seguir adelante.
Comenzamos en -2 -comenzamos en menos dos-,
y luego restamos 3, una vez más vamos a movernos
tres a la izquierda del -2, entonces vamos uno,
dos, tres, y terminamos en -5, esto es igual a
-5. Fíjense que en ambas situaciones restamos 3,
nos movimos tres a la izquierda en la recta
numérica; aquí comenzamos con 2 a la derecha
del 0, aquí comenzamos con 2 a la izquierda de 0,
este es -2. Hagamos otro ejemplo con estos mismos
números. Imaginemos -2 + 3. Los invito a pausar
el video e intentar resolverlo por su cuenta.
Entonces podríamos dibujar la recta numérica
de nuevo, y digamos que aquí tenemos -2, -1, 0,
1 y 2, comenzamos en -2, estamos 2 a la izquierda
de 0 y sumamos 3, así que ahora vamos a ir 3 a
la derecha: 1, 2, 3, y terminamos en 1 positivo.
Ahora pensemos en 2, 2 positivo y vamos a restar
3 negativo. Ya hemos hablado de esto en otros
videos, de hecho hay un video que explica por qué
los paréntesis tienen sentido. Cuando restamos un
número negativo es lo mismo que sumar el positivo,
así que 2 - 3 negativo es exactamente lo mismo
que 2 + 3 positivos. Estas dos operaciones son
equivalentes, y esto es igual a 5. Ahora sigamos
con otras variantes. Imaginemos 2 negativo - 3
negativo. Ahora bien, puede parecer realmente
intimidante tener todos estos signos negativos
aquí, pero sólo tenemos que recordar que restar
un número negativo es lo mismo que sumar, así que
esto es exactamente lo mismo que - 2 + 3 y -2 +
3 ya lo hemos visto justo aquí, empezamos en -2,
empezamos en 2 a la izquierda de 0 y luego vamos
a ir 3 a la derecha, estamos sumando 3: 1, 2, 3.